"Mortal Kombat Legends: Battle of the Realms" is a
study in contrasts. It has too much plot going on,
but it also has awesome action, ninjas,
and the voice of Joel McHale. Here are all
the best and worst things about "Mortal
Kombat Legends: Battle of the Realms."
Johnny Cage is a "Mortal Kombat" mainstay
going back to the very first entry of the
hit game series. He brings to life a strong
hero archetype, bravado and a sense of humor
as well. Looking at the discussions around
his absence in the recent live-action film,
and the fans' desires to see him
portrayed by the right actor,
it all shows how important he can
be to any project in the franchise.
Joel McHale was a shining part of the previous
"MK" animated movie, "Scorpion's Revenge,"
and he continues that streak as one of the
best characters in "Battle of the Realms."
His relationship with Sonya Blade
and the levity he offers is amusing
without taking away from
what's going on around him.
McHale has spoken about how
he improvised with his scenes,
and that may have helped make some of
his moments more genuine and funnier.
The only complaint, of course, is that Cage
never secures that big win in this adventure,
but he's still a memorable part of the Earthrealm
defenders, even while being a bit of a jerk.
There are many different realms in the
"Mortal Kombat" lore — several smaller ones,
and six primary worlds, but it's
rare that any others than Earthrealm,
Outworld, and Netherrealm get to play
much of a part in the adventures.
Even Edenia, where several characters hail from,
is usually relegated to a mention or the tiniest
flashback. Worlds like Chaosrealm and Seido
are barely mentioned even in the newer games,
having become afterthoughts in the
character endings for the most part.
This also means that smaller realms the
lore has introduced, like Vaeternus,
Zaterra, Arnyek, and Osh-Tekk, have
little chance of ever being relevant.
"Battle of the Realms" still has
a story that lives up to the name,
but it seems silly now to have hoped the film
would have seen our heroes go to these places
or even give us new information on them. Seeing
our champions jump across worlds for the various
fights would have been quite the treat, but even
on the worlds that were used, there weren't many
new details to be glimpsed. Even some of the
newer spots from the movie look as if they
were taken directly from the games, such as
the shots of Shinnok's chambers, apparently
directly inspired by the in-game cutscenes from
the Konquest mode of "Mortal Kombat: Armageddon."
"Scorpion's Revenge" gave fans a wonderful
look at the key parts of Shang Tsung's island,
but the sequel film opened the battlefield
up a bit, offering animators a chance to
show off some areas with which players
of the games have become quite familiar.
The majority of "Battle of the Realms" takes
place in Outworld, but beginning portions show
off a few locales on Earth, brief interludes in
Netherrealm, the meeting place of the Elder Gods,
and an incredible exercise in color
toward the end as realms begin to merge.
Most of these are gorgeous backgrounds and help
bring their individual parts of the story to life.
Most notable on Earth is the Lin Kuei temple,
a site that has been shown in different
forms before, but could never be explored
thoroughly enough. The audience sees a slow,
long shot of the main structure, the
outside courtyard, and a look at the
inner sanctum of the Grandmaster. Warm,
radiant, containing statues of famous
Lin Kuei warriors - it all ties together
the foreboding feeling the scene presents.
In Outworld, the participants express how
intimidating Shao Kahn's fortress is, and a
brief glimpse of his throne room shows off
that awesome green hue behind him — there
is a lot of detail put into the arena
where most of the fighting takes place.
These are all solid representations of the
stages, mostly inspired by the newer games,
but the extra bits help make
the worlds feel more alive.
One of the awesome things that the last couple
of "Mortal Kombat" games did was progress the
overall narrative, giving fans new events
and lore to chew on. With the subject matter
for "Battle of the Realms," there was hope
that the film would give us fresh tidbits of
lore or clarify some of the existing meta-plot.
This isn't just to learn more about the realms,
but a hope that fans could see deeper
backgrounds for various characters,
or some progression in the relationships they
share. None of this really happens, however,
with the exception of Liu Kang, which is only a
brief moment that shows the death of his parents.
What was that even connected to, and why were
those Tarkatans on Earth, hunting them down?
Those with a truly extensive knowledge of "Mortal
Kombat" could potentially fill in some gaps,
but not all of what fans tend to
believe is also considered to be canon,
so a film adaptation like this presents an
interesting opportunity to firm up aspects of
the series' lore. The real missed prospect here is
not providing anything new about the Elder Gods,
the newer Titans, or especially The One
Being, who plays a pivotal role at the end.
True, The One Being is supposed to be a
mysterious figure that no one truly comprehends,
but it seems like the writers purposefully guided
the plot around him — perhaps so they wouldn't
have to answer any questions or say something
new. It's a shame, and it feels like this
promising alternate story, though full of passion,
falls short of doing anything truly spectacular.
Although the last one did a fair job in
delivering on violence and bloodshed,
"Battle of the Realms"
pushed it just a bit further.
"Mortal Kombat" is a series that needs to embrace
its more vicious tendencies to feel at home;
judging by the creativity in some of these
murders, they are loving the recent R-ratings.
Audiences will see some brutal finishes and a
couple of interesting takes on classic fatalities,
but a large portion of the carnage
comes from the standard fighting,
dispatching grunts in the most
over-the-top way possible.
Not only is there a ton of decapitations,
bone-breaking, and the ripping out of perfectly
good body parts, but the first act takes
advantage of an army of disposable soldiers.
We see shots linger more when some of this
happens, and much of the art and animation
choices around these attacks are meant to accent
the savagery each fighter possesses when pushed.
This leads to the use of more X-ray
moves that never overstay their welcome.
One of the problems with movies like
this is the desire to throw in as
many extra characters as possible,
sometimes because it'll get the fans
excited to see one of their low-key
favorites — but more often than not,
they are in there because the script needed
someone to take a loss or eat a fatality.
For this installment, it seems like
Stryker and Jade took the bullet — both
are introduced by name, get some lines, and
do absolutely nothing else worth mentioning.
Jade's relation to Kitana isn't brought up at
all, and she gets her skull cracked open by
Sonya early on and then knocked off-screen
with an impressive uppercut from Liu Kang,
never to be seen again. Stryker, at least,
gets a little bit more time to shine. He may
be "the new guy," but he's also a capable hero,
and he at least receives a beautifully
disgusting death scene. Still, these are
two great characters that feel wasted and would
have benefited from more moments focused on them.
Scorpion and Sub-Zero are two of the most iconic
characters in the "Mortal Kombat" franchise,
but players have a soft spot for all of the
various palette-swapped ninja characters from
the games. Though "Scorpion's Revenge" gave
us the classic origin of the iconic ninja duo,
fans were excited to see the sequel bring
in Cyrax, Sektor, Smoke, and, of course,
the younger Sub-Zero, Kuai Liang, who's
seeking revenge for his dead brother.
These characters are all badass, and each
given at least a brief moment to shine.
Having their own storyline going
on outside of the tournament,
but with their robotic arsenals and elemental
powers, their fights almost steal the show.
That's right, "Battle of the Realms" crams the
Cyber Initiative story arc into a few spectacular
scenes. Many of these characters fight together
and against each other, giving fans a lot to
observe, especially when fighters like Scorpion
and Sub-Zero begin using their powers together.
But for many, the coolest bit is
getting to see Smoke in action,
building up the friendship and respect he
has for Kuai Liang, and watching the story
unfold after his change. It's hard not to wish
for more of it, but their mission eventually had
to feed into the bigger plot and take the focus
off of those incredibly cool ninja characters.
"Scorpion's Revenge" had its flaws, but
overall it pleased fans and gave them
a reason to believe a sequel would deliver
the goods. While "Battle of the Realms"
might be an adequate follow-up (especially
if only considering the first two acts),
something about the ending just doesn't sit
right. It isn't horrible, but is nowhere near
the quality of the rest of the film. The third
act is much crazier — which is expected — but
feels like it's from a different movie,
predominantly because of the two main fights.
The final battle against Shinnok
has a ton of moving parts,
and is on a much grander scale, with godlike
powers being thrown around. This makes sense,
but it loses a lot of the intensity – not to
mention the blood – of the previous encounters,
even if the stakes are sky-high. No one can call
this anticlimactic; a little boring, perhaps,
but there should be some negative points awarded
for only having a slightly better version of the
ending from "Mortal Kombat: Annihilation,"
with the giant dragon and everything.
The fight between Liu Kang and Shao Kahn may
be worse, however. Some of the moves look like
they were lifted directly from "Dragon Ball Z,"
but without the extra power levels to help it
make sense. Both of these encounters needed to
stay a bit more grounded to stick the landing.
Many of the "Mortal Kombat" characters have found
their voices over the lifespan of the series,
though the actors who portray them
often change. Even if what's coming
out of the combatants mouths might not
be a perfect recreation of recent games,
none of the voices in either of the two modern
animated movies have felt bad enough to stand out.
So, many of the talents who helped bring the cast
to life in "Scorpion's Revenge" returned to play
the characters again, which is a testament to
how well they did — and a great number of the
voice actors fill their parts perfectly,
with many of them playing multiple roles.
It's always fun to hear words like
"Kamidogu" and "Outworld" uttered
with such seriousness and precision.
New voices mix well with the old,
forming a bloody chorus of grunts and
screams that work perfectly for the film.
Animated features are typically shorter
than their live-action counterparts,
but "Battle of the Realms" clocks in at right
under 90 minutes. It's about nine minutes longer
than its predecessor — which again, tried
to cram too much into its plot — and here,
it's obvious that WB didn't learn from their
earlier mistake. The idea of not overstaying
your welcome is certainly admirable, but why
throw so much into the mix if that's the plan?
There's enough plot here for
two feature-length projects,
making matters even more overstuffed than
"Scorpion's Revenge." The champions of
Earthrealm going to a "final" tournament in
Outworld feels like a plot that easily could
have filled 90 minutes — but piled on top of
that is all the drama of the other stories too.
It'd be easy to go trim the fat, saving the
Kamidogu and The One Being for a follow-up tale
when a true final boss was required.
However, screenwriter Jeremy Adams
has implied that the "Mortal Kombat
Legends" films were a two-chapter story,
meaning they had to put everything in
because there might not be others to come.
If true, that is a huge shame, as doing so may
have hindered the overall story — and fans would
have likely welcomed further animated
films in the Mortal Kombat universe.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.